7月29日から8月の8日まで僕が毎日どこにいるのかを
言いましょう静岡東京東京東洋酒造が東京静岡東京静岡静岡東京
なんかねえ
忙しいんですよ柄じゃないとわけじゃないんですけどもやっぱり移動しちゃうとその一
眼
結構いっぱいになっちゃってて2に忙しく生活を送っております
肇社長です今を乗り越えると俺はこの先に夏休みがあると信じてん
例えば色々頑張ってるんですよ今日の動画ですね
地味に人気の質問コーナーの質問を募集
しようと思いますって
たいときで質問を募集しますあの質問コーナーなぜかめちゃくちゃ認知なんですよ
今までいろんな質問コーナーもやってたんですけどどれもなんかすごい評価がよって何
が楽しいの質問すぺー総会総会ならそれでいい夏の質問コーナーというわけですねこの
動画のコメントコメントの方に僕円に対する質問とかもリクエストからこの日圭著とか
質問
田中言いたいこととかなんか気になることとか何かやってほしいと彼は何でも好きな
この会社ってくださいなんか
な8ビット場でもいいからなんでも回転人に書いてドサクサに紛れて高評価をしてその
ノリでチャンネル登録もして
っていう感じで質問を募集します来週の c 4 p ごろまでこの動画のコメント欄
に書かれた質問を使って質問コーナーという僕が質問に答える没包んだ破ったらもう
なんかみんな好きなことを書いてください適当なことも何でもいいんでもどんどんやっ
てくださいそれに僕答えていくという動画を作ろうと思っております
どんな感じの動画になるかっていうのは今までの質問校
なく度も見ればわかるところで津波に最近はスプラトゥーンにハマってますすぎて皆
さんのコメントを待つしております
何でも書いてねなぜならちょっと多めに作業しようと思ってるんですよ
よかったら音色と女と書いてください
ああああああああ
じゃん
me